[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
mit ganz viel Sport ja guten Abend von
mir und das sind die Themen von heute
auf der Flucht getötet Raketen treffen
einen Bahnhof in der Ostukraine und
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
ist zu Besuch in Kiew
milliardenschwere Stoßdämpfer der Bund
schnürt ein Hilfspaket für Firmen die
von den Folgen des ukrainekriegs
betroffen sind
und teilschuldspruch für Boris Becker
der Tennislegende droht im Prozess wegen
Insolvenzverschleppung eine Haftstrafe
[Musik]
dieser 44 ist geprägt durch eine weitere
Eskalation Raketen auf einen Bahnhof
voller Flüchtlinge im Osten der Ukraine
50 Menschen sterben darunter fünf Kinder
fast 100 werden verletzt Präsident
selensky wirft Russland grenzenlose
Bösartigkeit vor Moskau dagegen
beschuldigt die Ukraine den Angriff
verübt zu haben Volker Duschek
für tausende ist der Bahnhof seit Tagen
der aufbruchsorte deine Welt ohne Bomben
und Angst auch heute sie wollen weg aus
kramertorsk denn hier wird womöglich
bald Krieg sein
gegen halb elf ist für viele Familien
nichts mehr wie es war zwei Raketen
schlagen plötzlich ein dutzende Menschen
sind sofort tot überall Trümmer Scherben
Blut eine Bombe mit Streumunition da
sind sich Augenzeugen sicher Belege
fehlen aber noch Autos sind auf dem
Bahnhofsvorplatz explodiert
ich war kurz Zigaretten kaufen dann die
Bomben als ich zum Auto zurückkam war
Oma tot ich bin losgerannt und habe
versucht anderen zu helfen
mehr als 150.000 Einwohner zählt die
Stadt im Osten hier kontrollieren die
Ukrainer noch das Geschehen doch moskau
will das ganze Gebiet von Donalds und
Lou hansk vor dem Bahnhof liegen die
Überreste einer Rakete mit der
russischen Aufschrift für unsere Kinder
Moskau weist jede Verantwortung zurück
unsere Armee nutzt diese Art von Raketen
nicht zudem haben heute keine Einsätze
in kremators stattgefunden oder waren in
kammertorsk geplant
der Kreml behauptet im Gegenzug der
Raketentyp werde nur von der
ukrainischen Armee verwendet auch hier
fehlen die Beweise
verabscheuungswürdig nennt die
eu-kommissionspräsidentinnen Angriff
Ursula von der Leyen ist heute mit ihrer
Delegation in Kiew als Zeichen der
Unterstützung im Gepäck neue Sanktionen
gegen Russland aus ukrainischer Sicht
allerdings nach wie vor zu wenig um den
Krieg zu beenden Anne Gellinek
Ortstermin in Butscher dem Ort an dem
die Gräuel des Krieges in der Ukraine
sichtbar wurden
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
steht plötzlich an einem Massengrab
deutlich schockiert zusammen mit dem
EU-Außenbeauftragten Josef Borrell will
sie sich einen Eindruck verschaffen
darüber was hier geschah
das Undenkbare ist hier passiert
wir haben das grausame Gesicht von
Putins Armee gesehen wir haben die
Rücksichtslosigkeit und Kaltherzigkeit
gesehen mit der Sie diese Stadt besetzt
haben
gestern Nacht waren von der Leyen und
Borell zehn Stunden lang mit dem Zug aus
Polen in die ukrainische Hauptstadt
gereist wo sie am späten Nachmittag auch
mit dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski zusammen
sie sind willkommen frau Präsidentin
sagt wolodi mir selensky zur Begrüßung
die Europäer haben ein Geschenk
mitgebracht der ebenfalls mitgereist des
slowakische Premierminister kündigt an
sein Land wolle der Ukraine das S300
Raketenabwehrsystem sowjetischer Bauart
überlassen zur Abwehr russischer
Angriffe
außerdem will die EU der Ukraine weitere
500 Millionen Euro zur Unterstützung der
Streitkräfte zur Verfügung stellen in
Botschaft hatten die Europäer auch
versprochen dass sie der Ukraine bei der
Aufklärung der Verbrechen mit eigenen
Ermittlern helfen werden der Besuch hier
ein Symbol ein Zeichen das die EU an der
Seite der Ukraine stehe und die ganze
Welt mit Butcher trauert
fragen wir Katrin Eugendorf in Kiew
welche Bedeutung hat dieser Besuch der
EU-Spitze für die Ukraine
eine sehr große dieser Besuch stand ja
nicht nur unter dem Eindruck von Butcher
sondern vor allem unter dem Eindruck von
dem was heute in grammatosk passiert ist
und Ursula von der Leyen hat die
Pressekonferenz damit begonnen dass sie
das als abscheuliche Tat Russlands
verurteilt hat und sie wirkte wirklich
sehr emotional insgesamt war das Treffen
zwischen silensky und Ursula von der
Leyen ein sehr finde ich emotionales
treffen Ursula von der Leyen ist sehr
weit gegangen indem sie dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten zugesichert hat dass die EU
100% an der Seite der Ukraine stünde
dass man den Beitrag Beitrittsprozess
für eine EU-Mitgliedschaft des Landes
der normalerweise Jahre dauert bereit
ist auf Wochen zu verkürzen und dass sie
sich da voll dafür einsetzen würde was
ich auch sehr wichtig fand Ursula von
der Leyen hat zu selensky gesagt dass
die Ukraine hier den Krieg Europas
ausfechtet und das sie alles tun wird
und das Europa alles tun wird um die
Ukraine in diesem Krieg zu unterstützen
das ist schon sehr viel und sie hat auch
noch mal versichert dass die Ukraine zur
europäischen Familie gehört ich habe
Präsident selensky dann auf dieser
Pressekonferenz gefragt ob er zufrieden
ist mit den Ergebnissen er ist ein
bisschen aus hat ein bisschen
ausweichend geantwortet aber schon
insgesamt den Eindruck vermittelt dass
das für die Ukraine ein kleiner
Fortschritt ist in den Beziehungen zu
Europa und dass dieser Rückhalt den
Ursula von der Leyen hier mit
ausgedrückt hat für die Ukraine sehr
wichtig ist Dankeschön Katrin Eigendorf
aus Kiew
mehr als
320.000 Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
haben hierzulande bereits Zuflucht
gefunden der Bund hat den Ländern nun
zugesagt einen Großteil der Kosten dafür
zu tragen insgesamt zwei Milliarden Euro
die geflüchteten erhalten den gleichen
Status wie anerkannte Asylbewerber damit
stehen Ihnen die Leistungen wie Hartz IV
Empfängern zu Alexander Pool berichtet
jeden Tag kommen am Münchner
Hauptbahnhof Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
an allein gestern waren es weit über 300
zumeist Frauen und Kinder nach einem
Beschluss von Bund und Ländern sollen
sie künftig genauso unterstützt werden
wie anerkannte Asylbewerber ab dem 1.6
diesen Jahres soll es so sein dass die
Flüchtlinge die Vertriebenen aus der
Ukraine die Grundsicherung für
Arbeitssuchende beziehen können außerdem
erhalten Sie eine Arbeitserlaubnis
werden krankenversichert und haben
Anspruch auf Kindergeld und Deutschkurse
über 320.000 Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
sind mittlerweile in Deutschland
angekommen an den Kosten für ihre
Integration wird sich der Bund nun
beteiligen 500 Millionen Euro für die
Unterbringung bekommen die Kommunen
weitere 500 Millionen erhalten die
Länder für bislang entstandene Kosten
für Gesundheit und Kinderbetreuung zahlt
der Bund noch einmal eine Milliarde Euro
die Länder alle sind allem zufrieden in
der Summe ist es vertretbar und wir
haben ja am Ende alle zugestimmt es ist
wichtig dass wir die Menschen schnell
aufnehmen Städte und Gemeinden fordern
aber weitere Anstrengungen es müssen
willkommensklassen in den Schulen
errichtet werden die Kitas müssen in
sehr kurzer Zeit ausgebaut werden all
das wird natürlich auch den Kommunen
noch mal erhebliches anfordern
Menschenrechtsorganisationen begrüßen
die Maßnahmen von Bund und Ländern sie
fordern aber dass diese künftig für alle
Asylbewerber gelten sollen
zwei Milliarden Euro das sind wie eben
gehört die Zuschüsse des Bundes für die
Flüchtlingshilfe
insgesamt werden die Folgen des Krieges
den Bundeshaushalt mit 24 Milliarden
Euro zusätzlich belassen das schätzt
Finanzminister Lindner auch viele
Unternehmen sind betroffen sie sollen
mit bis zu 5 Milliarden Euro unterstützt
werden Patricia Wiedemeier
gemeinsam verkündeten am Mittag der
Finanz- und der Wirtschaftsminister das
nicht nur die Bürger sondern auch die
Unternehmen die durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
werden entlastet werden sollen das was
wir als Paket Ihnen vorstellen ist ein
wirtschaftspolitischer Stoßdämpfer er
federt Härten ab verhindert
strukturbrüche aber er löst Marktkräfte
nicht auf und er geht
verantwortungsbewusst mit dem Geld der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler um
vor allem die hohen Energiepreise
bereiten vielen Unternehmen Probleme
kurzfristig Liquidität sicherzustellen
ein Ziel der Regierung geplant sind
unter anderem ein Kostenzuschuss für
energieintensive Unternehmen ca 5
Milliarden Euro Kredite der Förderbank
KfW ca 7 Milliarden und Kredite für
Firmen die von Energiebörsen abhängen
bis zu 100 Milliarden Euro ein
umfassendes Maßnahmenpaket umfassend
heißt allerdings nicht und das ist nicht
dass jede Härte weggenommen wird dass
jeder Verlust jeder mehr Euro für
Energie beispielsweise
ausgeglichen wird wir werden also die
Unternehmen und die Privatpersonen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
eine Last zu tragen haben für die
Opposition der richtige Weg Unternehmen
müssten dringend entlastet werden
deswegen kommt es vor allem darauf an
dass das Paket schnell umgesetzt wird es
muss schneller sein als beispielsweise
das zweite energieentlastungspaket das
bisher über die ankündigungsform nicht
hinausgekommen ist genau das sicherten
beide Minister heute zu schnell soll es
gehen aber auch das betonten sie die
Hilfen sein zeitlich begrenzt
eine große Mehrheit der Deutschen
befürwortet härtere Sanktionen gegen
Russland im aktuellen ZDF Politbarometer
sprechen sich 77% für Verschärfungen aus
18 Prozent dagegen Öl und Gasimporte aus
Russland wollen 28 % sofort stoppen die
meisten sind aber dafür sie erst zu
beenden wenn die Versorgung anderweitig
gesichert ist
das ausführliche Politbarometer gibt es
wie immer im heute journal ab 22 Uhr
schon jetzt finden Sie in unserer ZDF
heute App alle Zahlen und Umfragewerte
auch zum Wegfall der corona-maßnahmen
eine herbe Niederlage so bezeichnet
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach die
gescheiterte Impfpflicht ein neuer
Anlauf sei unwahrscheinlich ohne
Impfpflicht wird es im Herbst wohl neue
Beschränkungen geben müssen bis hin zu
lockdowns schätzen Ärzte zwar sinkt die
sieben Tage Inzidenz weiter liegt aber
immer noch bei rund 1.181 und weiterhin
sind 19,5 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland nicht geimpft Heikes
lanzgeber berichtet am Tag danach ein
zerknirschter Bundesgesundheitsminister
die von ihm geforderte Impfpflicht fand
gestern im Bundestag keine Zustimmung
einen erneuten Anlauf soll es laut
Bundeskanzler entgegen seiner
Überzeugung nicht geben es hat eine
klare und auch bittere Niederlage für
alle Impfpflicht Befürworter gegeben das
ist auch für mich der Fall natürlich
weil ich habe mich sehr intensiv und aus
Überzeugung
für die Einführung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht eingesetzt 76 Prozent der
Bevölkerung doppelt geimpft für
Lauterbach immer noch zu wenig den
Krankenhäusern jedoch droht derzeit
keine Überlastung mit covid-patienten
viel mehr plagt sie der Personalausfall
Pfleger und Ärzte infiziert obwohl qua
Gesetz hier alle geimpft sind seit Mitte
Februar stehen wieder immer mehr Ampeln
unserer Intensivstation auf Rot derzeit
knapp 40 Prozent der Grund im Moment ist
vor allen Dingen fehlendes und dieses
Mal vor allen Dingen erkranktes Personal
die gute Nachricht der Höhepunkt der
omicron-welle sei überwunden doch der
Minister sorgt sich bereits um den
Herbst dann läuft das
Infektionsschutzgesetz aus dass er auf
einen Basisschutz gestutzt hatte und
kündigt an wir können mit dem was wir
jetzt wissen mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht ohne eine
maskenpflicht zum Beispiel in den Herbst
hineingehen eine bittere Woche für Karl
lauter der weiterhin unbeirrt fürs
impfen wirbt nicht wissend welchen Lauf
das Coronavirus nehmen wird
nach Frankreich wo übermorgen
Präsidentschaftswahl ist genauer gesagt
deren erster Teil denn zunächst wird
sich entscheiden wer in die Stichwahl in
zwei Wochen kommt ziemlich sicher sind
das Amtsinhaber immeruel macron und die
Rechtspopulistin Marine Le Pen alle
anderen Bewerber scheinen abgeschlagen
der Ausgang aber ist absolut offen denn
macron liegt nur noch knapp vor seiner
härtesten Konkurrentin Christel Haas
berichtet
da hängen Sie die Kandidaten nicht auf
Plakaten sondern auf Socken wenn der
Wahlkampf so leichtfüßig wäre er wird
begleitet von Corona und dem
ukrainekrieg als Krisenmanager erhielt
Emmanuel macron gute Umfragewerte doch
diese Effekt ist vorbei bei seinem
einzigen großen Wahlkampfauftritt warnt
er davor seine Gegner zu unterschätzen
das ist der Kampf des Fortschritts gegen
die Abschottung es ist der Kampf des
Patriotismus und von Europa gegen die
Nationalisten
denn sie ist ihm laut Umfragen dicht auf
den Fersen die Rechtspopulistin Marine
lepin sie verspricht den Franzosen mehr
Kaufkraft ist Euro skeptisch und will
die Zuwanderung stark begrenzen
Frankreich wird entweder in einem großen
globalistischen Magma untergehen mit der
EU als Auftakt oder unsere Nation
besteht weiter als sicherer Hafen für
die Franzosen
dennoch wird sie fast schon als gemäßigt
wahrgenommen denn der noch viel rechtere
Eric Simu hat noch radikalere Positionen
und noch ein Kandidat macht sich
Hoffnung diesmal auf dem linken Rand
Jean-Luc Milos er will eine Neue
Republik gründen und raus aus der NATO
immerhin über 40% der Franzosen wollen
am Sonntag für einen Kandidaten am
rechten oder linken Rand stimmen
für die Stichwahl sagen die Umfragen
eine Neuauflage des Duells makro-lübben
voraus dieses Mal aber ist die
Rechtspopulistin stärker als noch vor
fünf Jahren es könnte also eng werden
für macron diese Wahl ist für ihn alles
andere als ein Durchmarsch
nach dem gestrigen Anschlag in Tel Aviv
mit drei Toten hat israels
Ministerpräsident Bennet vor weiteren
Angriffen und Nachahmungstätern gewarnt
gestern Abend feuerte ein Palästinenser
laut Polizei in einer Bar in die Menge
er wurde von Sicherheitskräften
erschossen es war der vierte Anschlag in
rund zwei Wochen insgesamt wurden 13
Menschen getötet
und jetzt noch was in eigener Sache die
Chefetage im ZDF ändert sich und wird
deutlich weiblicher Bettina Schausten
übernimmt am 1 Oktober die Chefredaktion
programmdirektorin wird Nadine Wilke der
Verwaltungsrat stimmte heute den
Vorschlägen von Intendant Norbert
Himmler zu Susanne Gehlert hat Details
es sind zwei erfolgreiche zdf-frauen die
künftig ganz oben mitbestimmen ein
starkes Team für ein starkes ZDF so der
Intendant Bettina Schausten und Nadine
Bilke stehen für exzellenten
Journalismus aber auch für ein
innovatives Programmmanagement mit der
Komplettierung der Geschäftsleitung
können wir nun gemeinsam am Ziel
arbeiten dass wir für die ganze
Gesellschaft ein ausgezeichnetes
öffentlich-rechtliches Programm machen
und das für alle ausspielwege den Sender
ZDFneo leitet Nadine Wilke seit 2018
nach langer Erfahrung im Bereich
digitale Medien mit Neuentwicklungen und
Serien fürs junge Publikum
Fernsehen das ist natürlich immer noch
ein linearer Kanal das ist sehr sehr
wichtig gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
verstärkt auf die Mediathek setzen auf
Social Media und auf die Interaktion mit
unserem Publikum auf diesem Weg ist das
ZDF bereits unterwegs und diesen Weg
möchte ich weitergehen guten Abend was
Bettina Schausten ist als Chefin der
aktuellen Programme und Moderatorin von
Nachrichten Wahl und was nun Sendungen
den Publikum seit vielen Jahren bekannt
das hätte elf steht für
Qualitätsjournalismus und gerade in
diesen Zeiten von Krieg und Krise zeigen
wir glaube ich was wir leisten können
ein attraktives Informationsangebot
jetzt auch ins Netz zu transferieren für
jüngere Menschen ist die Zukunftsaufgabe
auf die freue ich mich und nehmen sie
gerne an ab Oktober stehen dann drei
Frauen und drei Männer an der Spitze des
ZDF
Boris Becker sein naiv aber unschuldig
sagt seinen Verteidiger die Geschworenen
in London sehen das anders sie sind
überzeugt dass der ehemalige Tennisstar
sein Vermögen im Insolvenzverfahren
teilweise bewusst verschleiert hat dem
54-Jährigen drohen jetzt bis zu sieben
Jahre Haft aus London Yassin hairline
beim Verlassen des Gerichtsgebäudes
heute Nachmittag verriet Boris Beckers
Gesicht nicht wie im zumute war die drei
Wochen Verhandlung vor dem Server Crown
Code in London hatten der Öffentlichkeit
noch einmal das turbulente Leben des
Tennisstars vor Augen geführt Beispiel
Anklagepunkt 16
das Verbergen des Pokals seines ersten
bündelten Sieges 1985 vor den
Insolvenzverwaltern in diesem Fall
befand die Jury Becker für nicht
schuldig in vier von 24 Anklagepunkten
allerdings schon darunter die
gravierenden Tatbestände der nicht
Offenlegung von Immobilien und
Aktienwerten und die Verschleierung von
Schulden
die Staatsanwältin warf Becker vor die
Insolvenzverwalter absichtlich getäuscht
zu haben und verwies auf dessen frühere
Verurteilung wegen Steuerhinterziehung
in Deutschland Beckers Verteidiger
argumentierte sein Mandant habe sich auf
sein Tennis konzentrieren wollen und sei
hoffnungslos überfordert gewesen im
Umgang mit Geld die Bemessung des
Strafmaßes obliegt nun der Richterin und
wird am 29 April bekannt gegeben Bäcker
droht eine Gefängnisstrafe von bis zu
sieben Jahren
jetzt zur Fußball Europa League Norbert
da sind die Frankfurt Fans ganz aus dem
Häuschen nach dem viertelfinalheim Spiel
gestern ein bärenstarker Auftritt der
Eintracht eigentlich so wie immer wenn
es gegen die ganz großen geht und wie
immer fantastisch unterstützt vom
heimischen Publikum Barcelona
schwächelte konnte aber dank eines
einzigen Geniestreichs zum eins zu eins
der Niederlage knapp in drinnen das
Unentschieden fühlt sich an wie ein Sieg
die Eintracht bietet ihren Fans einen
großen Kampf gegen den fünfmaligen
Champions league-gewinner und geht
verdient kurz nach der Pause in Führung
Knauf gelingt ein Traumtor
technisch perfekt und zu platziert für
Torwart ter Stegen
Gänsehaut-Atmosphäre in der
vollbesetzten Arena ausgelöst durch den
erst 20 Jahre alten Ansgar Knauf heute
gibt es
keinen Wermutstropfen sondern nur ein
großes großes Kompliment an die Spieler
für diese herausragende Leistung doch
barcel
ona sein Spiel schon immer ausgezeichnet
hat eine direktkombination mit Ferran
Torres als Letzter Station der Ausgleich
nach Gelb-Rot für tuta bringt Frankfurt
das Remy auch mit zehn Spielern über die
Zeit ein magischer Abend und ein
passender Vorgeschmack auf das Rückspiel
in einer Woche im riesigen Stadion von
Barcelona
ebenfalls eins zu eins endete das Europa
leagueviertelfinal Hinspiel der
Leipziger gegen Bergamo die starken
Gäste aus Italien gingen in der 17
minute durch Louis Muriel in Führung in
der 58 minute scheiterte der Leipziger
André Silber mit einem vollef Meter am
bergamustorwart Ruan Musso kurz danach
das Eigentor von antalanter durch Davidi
Zappa Costa in der 58 Minute das den
Sachsen immerhin noch das Remy bescherte
das DFB-Sportgericht hat den Einspruch
des SC Freiburg nach dem Wechselfehler
der Bayern zurückgewiesen bei dem
Münchner 4:1 Sieg vergangenen Samstag in
Freiburg hatte der FCB für wenige
Sekunden mit zwölf Spielern auf dem Feld
gestanden die Verantwortung dafür so
dass Urteil des dfb-leger aber nicht bei
den Bayern der Wechselfehler sei viel
mehr Folge eines schuldhaften Verhaltens
des Schiedsrichters
Freiburg hat übrigens darauf verzichtet
Einspruch einzulegen der bayernsieg ist
damit sozusagen besiegelt auch das ist
gut Dankeschön Norbert
noch ist es draußen ungemütlich mit
Regen und Schnee wie es weitergeht sagt
uns gleich östendermi Christian Sievers
begrüßt sie im heute journal um 10 wir
wünschen Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende
danke für Ihr Interesse und bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter den nächsten
Stunden gibt es noch kräftigen
Schneefall vor allem den Mittelgebirgen
und Regen das verabschiedet sich
allmählich nach Süden aber morgen kommt
noch mal Kaltluft von Nordwesten her und
dann bilden sich Schauer und Gewitter
und die ziehen ebenfalls südwärts weiter
aber das Hoch hier ganz im Westen dehnt
sich allmählich aus und in den nächsten
Tagen ab Montag wird es deutlich ruhiger
und freundlicher in der Nacht ist es
aber noch ziemlich durchwachsen im Süden
teils mit Sturm Regen den höheren Lagen
Schnee in den Mittelgebirgen ebenfalls
da bis zu 10 cm Neuschnee und es kann
sogar bis ins Flachland runterschneiden
in der Mitte in den Frühstunden bilden
sich ganz im Norden Gewitter weil
tiefsten Temperaturen von -1° in der
Eifel und fünf Grad Richtung Bayern und
morgen im Tagesverlauf also schauen und
Gewitter die ziehen allmählich
südostwärts im Südwesten macht sich
schon der hohe Luftdruck bemerk und die
Sonne kommt häufiger hervor bei höchsten
Temperaturen von vier bis elf Grad den
nächsten Tagen vor allem dann am Sonntag
noch Schauer und im Südwesten
Sonnenschein bei 6 bis 13 Grad danach
wird es wärmer Dienstag bis 22 Grad ein
schönen Abend